ils peuvent passer des semaines sans
naviguer leurs acquisitions est
important jugé vital par la garde
côtière recherche et sauvetage
surveillance des pêches sûreté maritime
les navires sont neufs et pourtant ils
ne peuvent jouer pleinement leur rôle
parce que mal construit le capitaine
hervé adamson on croit toujours pas à
ses yeux il a passé 33 ans dans la garde
côtière et pour lui c'est tout
simplement scandaleux
la devise de la garde côtière est simple
sécurité d'abord servez ce constant ce
qui est en train de se produire mais
surtout ce qui s'est produit
reflète un tout autre portrait et
soulève de sérieuses questions
qu'est ce qui se passe ici c'est
vraiment inhabituel
ces navires ont coûté beaucoup d'argent
et vol par effraction
la facture de 194 millions est encore
plus élevée prévue
des documents obtenus par radio-canada
grâce à la loi sur l'accès à
l'information confirment qu'ils ont non
seulement coûté 33 millions de plus mais
que de nombreux problèmes sont survenus
une fois les vaisseaux aux livres et les
neuf navires tous identiques ont été
construits par le chantier un ring
d'halifax
il y à déjà de la corrosion
ce genre de problème qui ne devrait pas
survenir avant peut-être 20 ans mauvaise
soudure mauvaise installation mauvais
choix de matériaux infiltrations d'eau
dans des boîtes électriques défauts de
conception
ahmet reprises des rapports de
réclamations souligne que la sécurité du
personnel à bord peut être compromise or
un ancien fonctionnaire qui a travaillé
étroitement au projet va encore plus
loin
il a accepté de dénoncer ce qu'il a vu à
condition que son identité soit protégé
à bruz plus trop si vous regardez de
près le contrat vous constaterez que le
tour n'est pas conforme
probablement que la plupart des navires
ont des problèmes mais il y a plus
encore nommons le chu
selon lui les problèmes sont si
importants que les navires n'aurait
jamais dû être accepté tel quel par le
gouvernement quand vous construisez
quelque chose d'aussi gros et d'aussi
complexe
il est normal que des problèmes
surviennent cependant si ces navires
étaient des navires étrangers et qu'ils
franchissaient le territoire canadien
je crois que les autorités canadiennes
il retiendrait akyé et voilà que dans un
appel d'offres qui vient d'être publié
travaux publics admet aujourd'hui que
les navires peuvent même être instable
s'ils naviguent dans certaines
conditions météo leur capacité à
composer avec le givre est limité
l'absence de richesses pour drainer la
structure fait en sorte que l'on peut
rester emprisonné encore là affecter
sérieusement la stabilité avec son
expérience en mer cela fait dire au
capitaine adam ce que les conséquences
pourraient être catastrophiques pour
supporter si la glace s'accumulent
l'équipage pourrait avoir abandonné le
navire
pire encore le navire pourrait chavirer
une personne elle pourrait y rester
je crois que c'est un scénario plus
probable mais comment at on pu en
arriver là
le reste de l'histoire est plutôt
troublant on nous a ordonné de ne pas
rapporter ces problèmes à la garde
côtière ni à personne d'autre
on nous a carrément ordonné de minimiser
les difficultés des sources confirment à
radio canada que les signaux d'alarmé
ont été ignorés que l' affaire a été
étouffée par le gouvernement pour des
considérations politiques
le contexte est important quelques mois
plus tôt le gouvernement conservateur
venait d'accorder à irving les droits de
construction d'un méga projet celui des
navires de combat de la marine
canadienne
maintenant évaluée à environ 36
milliards de dollars toujours selon nos
sources les ratés risquait d'entraîner
des délais et d'attirer l'attention mais
surtout de remettre en question le choix
du gouvernement
mon expérience me dit que le
gouvernement aurait des questions à
poser aux ministères qui ont géré ce
dossier
travaux publics a donc accepté les
navires transports canada lisa certifiés
et la garde côtière en a pris possession
saumon mais quelqu'un doit être tenu
responsable
quelqu'un a été irresponsable en
attendant corriger les problèmes
pourrait coûter des dizaines de millions
$ aux contribuables
lille 9 patrouilleurs devait être la
première grande étape dans le
renouvellement de la flotte de la garde
côtière
le voyage a plutôt mal commencé
on marque le fabricant des bateaux
l'entreprise irving a déjà réagi à votre
reportage qui nous avons marre des
céline une entrevue a choisi de répondre
par voie de communiqué en gros le
chantier rejettent la responsabilité
c'est raté et je sais les navires ont
été construits selon les indications
détaillées de la garde côtière et
respecte les exigences de sécurité de
transport canada ils se sont avérées
extrêmement efficace voilà alors du côté
du gouvernement trudeau des réactions
toujours par réaction au même si
quelques ministères sont interpellés
pêches et océans de qui relève la garde
côtière transports canada bien sûr et
travaux publics qui a accepté les
navires tels quels on peut imaginer que
l'opposition officielle est un peu mal
placé pour critiquer ce qui s'est passé
même si ça soulève énormément de
questions vous aurez compris céline
qu'il est difficile d'imaginer les
conservateurs de se montrer très
critique et d'exploiter cette affaire là
en chambre au cours des prochains jours
par contre dans ses ministres devront
peut-être justifier ce qui s'est passé
en effet merci beaucoup marque au revoir